i'm current davina and this
is remember when the show about old
stories in gaming history
told with new perspectives and today
we're looking back on nintendo's
greatest console failure
the wii u and how it led to one of its
greatest achievements
the nintendo switch back in 2005 the wii
changed not just how we played games but
who could be
gamers it broadened the market from
children and teenagers to
pretty much anyone and everyone the wii
gave nintendo position in gaming that
just
few other consoles ever get to have but
its follow-up
the wii u wasn't just only confusing but
it squandered the wii success
so what happened how did we go from
something that almost
everyone just instinctively knew how to
use to
well this something that not a whole lot
of people understood
we go any further i need to clear the
air on something now i
did work at nintendo back in 2013
in the debugging game testing
compartment there he is however
my time there holds absolutely no
bearings in what eventually happened to
the wii u
but still nonetheless it's important i
mention it
okay on with the show
let's start at the beginning eight years
back at e3 president of nintendo america
reggie fisa may took the stage to reveal
the eagerly awaited follow-up
to the wii there is one more order of
business left for us today
to make a proper introduction to a new
gaming companion
now it's kind of impossible to predict
what nintendo will do next but
what they revealed that day was
certainly unsuspecting
and at first glance it was kind of
difficult to understand
exactly what it was so to demonstrate
this
i wanted to see how my friends would
fare explaining it to me as though i had
absolutely
no idea about it at all this is michael
what would you consider your official
title again uh editor
scene make me senior editor and this is
miranda
explain to me what the wii u is as
though i have
no idea what it is at all the wii u is
the sequel
to the wii and has a separate game pad
uh as a tablet oh it has a tablet and a
lot of the same games as the wii
and everything else is pretty much the
same as the wii so
before you knew that there was going to
be a switch nintendo was testing it out
see we know that
now in a way it just kind of looks like
a clunky
switch it's kind of a prototype switch
yeah
that's all that's what i'm gonna go with
uh with the little
tablet the wii u was
a game console
that tried to be a local mobile
console if that makes sense that's jeff
bakalar he's an editor for cena
and was actually there at the wii u's
reveal i do remember feeling
a next console reveal was uh it felt
early
what i remember from that reveal is they
played this sort of pre-shot and
produced video
of just like all these whack-a-doo
things you would be doing with a wii u
and i specifically remember just sort of
looking around after the lights came up
after that video and everyone's sort of
just being like
what the hell is this contraption in
those events you have the kind of like
fan
boy people who are just losing their
minds because it's anything nintendo
but i definitely remember this very
vivid and and clear like lucid feeling
of like
oh no this doesn't seem like this is the
right direction at all
now to me there were some good ideas in
there like asymmetrical multiplayer for
example where
one player would be playing only on the
gamepad while others
use the tv to see it from a different
point of view that's an interesting idea
and the secondary screen is an inspiring
take on managing your inventory
looking at maps and menu screens those
things clicked to me from a gaming
standpoint
but then there were other things that
didn't really click
like the over emphasis of a new
controller rather than saying
it was a new system or the fact that
there was a
camera to video chat with people or
that they were really pushing it being a
web browser
and that it was also a universal tv
remote
oh that's right the whole tv thing i do
remember back in new york
going to an event right before release
and i had all these questions prepared
or like
what's the support going to look like we
got and like a dozen
questions specifically relating to the
tv
notion of this console and they were all
just like
we'll wait and see we don't know how
it's going to work and i just remember
being like
this thing's dead on arrival it inflated
into a video game console with a tablet
that was kind of an upgraded wii that
also had video chat and was an
all-around entertainment device it was
like
a nintendo swiss army knife and
some of us were excited for it or at
least wanted it
while others definitely didn't
the day after the wii u's reveal at e3
nintendo stock plummeted 7.5
an analyst said quote there were high
expectations from the new version of the
wii
and this fell far short all of which
put nintendo's share price at the lowest
it had been
in five years so
why did nintendo go this route it needed
to leverage the success of the wii
and the wii brand which was all
consuming within gaming at the time
that's the more hussein gamespots
managing editor and remember when
regular
for many years the global kind of
awareness around gaming
happened because of the wii so nintendo
couldn't cut that a loose and let it go
and move on to something entirely
but at the same time you sell a wii to a
to a
a grandma or an uncle or someone or
whoever it may be
they're gonna buy that with wii sports
and they're set for life
grandma isn't picking up xenoblade
chronicles after that
the wii pummeled the xbox 360 and ps3
that generation and not by being
this high-tech video game console but by
instead introducing a new way of play
for everyone not just gamers and i mean
everyone was playing the wii my mom was
playing the wii families were just
filming their kids playing the wii and
putting on youtube just because
nintendo was appealing to a massive
demographic that other consoles weren't
but as time went
on the wii was facing two major
challenges in its old age
one it wasn't hd compatible which the
world transitioned to
and two while certainly captured a
broader more
casual demographic it was missing the
mark on the most
important group in the gaming industry
core gamers
for that audience uh the wii lacked the
appealing
experience that its contemporaries had
and along with graphical limitations
its most innovative feature motion
controls
wasn't the most attractive way to play
all games nintendo still needed to
appeal to our audience and also for his
own
like brand strength he needed to create
exclusive titles
that attracted the core audience and
kept them faithful
by trying to have its cake and eat it
too created this
console that was just mediocre to its
core but also
full of amazing games that no one cared
about
the whole ordeal put the nintendo wii in
a category separate from the xbox 360
and ps3
in simplest terms think of it as casual
gamers and then over here
traditional hardcore gamers nintendo
needed to figure out a way to close this
gap something that would bridge these
two demographics into
gaming harmony cue the wii u
the wii u had hd and also a nintendo
like rendition of a traditional
controller appeasing
to this audience and then it had
everything that the wii had appeasing to
that audience
so going back and watching that reveal
with this in mind kind of makes it a
little clearer with what nintendo was
trying to do whether or not you or i
feel that they communicated that
properly to its consumers
or its stockholders the wii u came out
in 2012 and out of the gate
it sold decent a few people bought it
but
as time went on sales very quickly
started
to decline just a little after a year of
it being
out it sold about 3.9 million
units and for perspective the wii sold
9 million units within its first year
as a result of this nintendo's ceo awada
cut his own salary in half for five
months and
apologized for wii u struggling sales
[Music]
in time nintendo's first party games are
what defined this console showing it
in its best light and truly embodying
the capabilities
of its main feature the gamepad games
like pikmin 3 mario kart 8 super mario
3d world
splatoon both the wind waker and
twilight princess zelda hd remasters
and super mario maker which was this
console's defining moment that game
would be
impossible without a second screen
meanwhile the console did get some
pretty good third party support
games like zombie u really heightened
the suspense of having to manage your
inventory
games like wonderful 101 emphasized
having to draw on the gamepad and then
there's other games that got full-on
retreatments like batman arkham city
just
to utilize the gamepad also we can't
not mention amiibo which was an
incredible take on the
toys to life craze that happened with
stuff like skylanders
but even with really good games decent
third-party support
and the collecting craze that was
amiibos it just
wasn't enough nintendo missed the mark
on both gamers
and the average consumer who didn't
really seem to understand
what this was and if there was one game
that was truly defining in nintendo's
pivot
to something new it was breath of the
wild
breath the wild was initially designed
from the ground up for the wii u
with the sheikah slate representing the
second screen organizing inventory
maps so on however the game's director
hidemiro fujibayashi
began experiencing a breaking of
immersion by looking down
between the screen and the gamepad he
said quote in doing our testing without
the touch features we noticed looking
back and forth between the gamepad and
the screen
actually took a little something away
from this type of zelda game without the
touch features it actually turned out to
be a really strong gameplay experience
after more experimentation and testing
out we realized that this is the best
way to experience the game
the very idea they pitched this entire
system on started to get deconstructed
by its own developers now breath of the
wild was initially supposed to come out
two years before its 2017 release
but was delayed twice in favor of
porting it
to the nintendo switch since then nearly
every single wii u game has
found its way onto the switch and i have
to reiterate
the word nearly eventually nintendo
started marketing the wii u
as a console geared towards children
here's mom
we already have a wee sweetie cans
here's you
we use a total upgrade mother a stark
contrast in comparison to the switch
which
in its reveal showcased primarily adults
living a way cooler life
than i could possibly ever imagine the
switch reveal was a completely
wordless demonstration of what the
switch was and what it was capable of
and showing off familiar games like
skyrim felt like a punctuation mark on
the entire thing
the switch iterated on the wii u's
gamepad and somehow
delivered on the thing that everybody
wanted from the wii u in the first place
and that was the ability
to take it further than their bathroom
but anywhere in the world the wii u
despite being nintendo's worst selling
console to date
really served as a public prototype and
commercial experiment for ideas
that led to the switch and certain
aspects of it like amiibo still continue
to exist outside its lifespan and get
support
on the switch but the most telling thing
is that nintendo through
generations of experimentation and
unabashed risk taking from both its
handheld consoles and its home ones
managed to make something that is
truly remarkable when it comes to a
video game console and
this generation actually managed to blur
the lines between
casual and hardcore gamers the switch
didn't even have any extra features like
being a universal tv remote or a
built-in camera
it doesn't even have a web browser its
sole purpose is to play
games and since 2017 has sold over four
times
more than the wii u managed to do in its
entire lifespan
so it's hard to imagine we would have
had the switch if it wasn't for the
misstep
of the wii u
[Music]
till next time see you later
if you've made it this far thank you so
much for tuning in watching
this episode of remember what now this
is one of
three videos in the console trilogy if
you want to
call that that we were doing for
remember when and uh a link to the other
ones will be in a playlist in the
description
below anyways that's all i got
thank you so much wear a mask be well
this hill is killing me right now and
i'm current avina by the way
pleasure meeting you anyways i'll leave
you alone until next time
see you later